[Music]  in 1634 amsterdam was captivated by a  flower rich and poor animals on the  tulip market sophia was a beautiful  orphan chosen by one of the richest men  in the city love on earth and obey  [Music]  i've decided to engage the services of a  painter don't move put your brush to  capturing my wife she's a rare beauty  they'll say look at that lucky old dog  didn't he have a lovely young wife first  to flower first of all  [Music]  to do business I think it's the answer  to my problems if I were rich I could  take you away he would find us he will  not stop looking for me Ellis was dead  my lord I pray that my wife shall be not  of corruptible seed you've been busy  you've not been painting no offense I  made a plan to save us both we will be  together there's nothing that risk  I tell your husband what you've built  right  I bought the fierce fighter  [Music]  you do really think I'll carry this off  dear father love honor and obey  I mean Oh  [Music]